car tester michelle austyn maka realizes
that views can differ vastly on the
ideal city car for some it may be a
compact car for others a mini SUV this
Suns pulsar strikes the balance between
practicality and versatility this Sun
launched the Pulsar in 2015 it's
specially designed for the European
market and it's built in Barcelona
starting at 18,000 euros in Germany the
Pulsar is priced to appeal mainly to
young car buyers we tested a pulsar with
a gasoline-powered engine at the upper
end of the range it's 140 kilowatts can
push it from 0 to 100 km/h and 7.7
seconds the top of the range techni
variant commands a minimum price of
almost 27,000 euros in Germany
the Tecna includes for example LED
headlights as standard
the pulsars 2.7 meter wheelbase is the
longest of any car in the compact
segment that adds up to lots of space
inside
the high rear spoiler and the hint of an
underbody give the design a cutting edge
look top to bottom
folding the rear seat down adds another
thousand liters to the 385 litre cargo
space giving the Pulsar lots of room for
luggage if only it had a level floor in
the transporter configuration but it
doesn't
Michelle takes the compact out on the
town to test it and everyday traffic
situations
it's enough she notes that the color
ought to be an attention-getter and for
city driving a start/stop system is
indispensable the start/stop helps the
driver save fuel it automatically shuts
down the engine after its idle for a
certain time helping cut down a noise
pollution into the bargain
that's me the one thing Michelle doesn't
like about the interior is the center
console to her it looks as if someone
had plunked a huge block down here
instead of integrating it smoothly into
the dashboard otherwise the interior is
very high-quality with leather trim on
the steering wheel and seats as part of
the Tecna package the model we tested
was a six-speed stick shift but other
engines come in optional automatic
versions as well
and the spaciousness of the backseat can
set an example the pulsars technological
features are no less impressive the
360-degree display is a big help when
backing into a parking space with every
corner in full view the driver can avoid
many a scratch and ding in tight spots
the driver can access more assists by a
second display between the speedometer
and tachometer among them a lane
departure warning blind spot warning and
emergency brake assist the blind spot
warning helps the drivers stay on top of
things especially on the highway once
they've got the hang of it beginners and
Road veterans both can benefit from it
these safety features are part of the
overall techno line the lower-priced
equipment levels still deliver a
comprehensive city car on longer trips
to the nimble pulsar offers plenty of
scope for adventure
I invited Michelle sees the big
advantage of the Pulsar in its
spaciousness of course it's easier to
find a parking spot in a small car but
the Pulsar is also a viable alternative
for hobbyists with lots of equipment to
haul around such as personal associates
pure lighting fuel